PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you've been
doing definite integration
for the last couple of lectures.
And you've just started
with the fundamental theorem
of calculus.
So, that gives us this
whole powerful tool
to compute a bunch of integrals.
So, with that in mind, I've
got a couple questions for you.
So compute the
definite integrals.
The integral from pi over
6 to pi over 3 of tan x dx.
And the integral of minus pi
over 3 to pi over 3 of tan x
dx.
So why don't you
pause the video,
take a couple minutes to
work on those, come back
and we'll work on them together.
All right.
Welcome back.
So, as we were saying
we have a couple
of definite integrals here.
So one tool for definite
integrals is Riemann sums.
So, in principle, we could write
down a Riemann sum for, say,
this first integral here.
And then try and compute it
by trying to compute the sum
and taking a limit of it.
But I think it's pretty clear
that, for a function like tan
x, that's going to be
really, really hard to do.
So we want to not use
Riemann sums here.
And the way we can
not use Riemann sums
is using this great
tool that we have,
which is the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
So the fundamental
theorem of calculus says,
when you have a definite
integral, instead of computing
Riemann sums, what you can do
is compute an antiderivative
and use the antiderivative to
find out what the integral is.
Just compare two values
of the antiderivative
and that'll give you the value
of the definite integral.
So, in particular, let's do
this first integral first.
So we have the integral from
pi over 6 to pi over 3 of tan
x dx.
Well, so, we know what the
antiderivative of tan x is.
We did that in an
earlier recitation.
So that's ln of cosine x.
Or ln of the absolute
value of cosine x.
So, the fundamental
theorem of calculus
says that the value of
this definite integral,
in order to compute
it, we just take
the difference of that
antiderivative at pi over 3
and at pi over 6.
So, by the fundamental
theorem of calculus
this is equal to ln of the
absolute value of cosine
x for x between pi
over 6 and pi over 3.
So, OK, so this, you know,
this is this notation
that Professor
Jerison introduced.
So what does this actually mean?
It's just a shorthand for ln
of the absolute value of cosine
of pi over 3 minus ln
of the absolute value
of cosine of pi over 6.
Now, we could leave
our answer like this
but we can also
manipulate it and put it
in a little nicer form.
So, cosine of pi over 3 is-- oh,
I'm sorry I've made a mistake.
So it's not ln of
absolute value cosine x.
It's minus ln of absolute
value of cosine x.
Sorry about that.
So this is minus ln cosine
pi over 3 plus-- OK, so
minus and minus there is plus.
All right.
Sorry about that.
OK, so, good.
All right.
And we can pick up where I was
in the middle of my sentence
and OK, so we can just evaluate
this by just evaluating.
So cosine of pi over 3,
that's going to be 1/2.
So this is minus ln and absolute
value of 1/2 is just a 1/2.
Plus cosine of pi over 6
is square root of 3 over 2.
So plus ln square
root of 3 over 2.
And now you can use
your logarithm rules
to combine those into
a single expression.
So this is equal to ln
of square root of 3.
Or you could even use one more
logarithm rule if you wanted.
So this is equal to 1/2 ln of 3.
So all of those are, you
know, equivalent expressions
for the same number,
which is the value
of this definite integral.
OK, so, for the second
integral now, we
can do exactly the same
thing if we wanted to.
And it'll be a very
similar process.
You'll write down this
antiderivative here,
you'll take the
difference in values.
We can also do something a
little bit clever for this one.
Which is, definite
integrals have
some geometric
interpretation, right?
And if you think
about the function tan
x-- so we could put up
a little graph here--
so in between minus pi
over 3 and pi over 3,
tan x maybe looks
something like this.
Yeah, you know, give or take.
OK, so what's
important about this?
Well tan x is an odd function.
And this interval from-- this
is minus pi over 3 to pi over 3,
and this is the
curve y equals tan x.
So this is an odd function.
So the integral in question
is this positive area
minus this negative area.
But since it's an odd
function, it's symmetric.
So those two cancel
out perfectly.
So for the second one, you
could do the same process
that we did.
But you can also use a little
bit of geometric reasoning
to realize that this second
one is just equal to 0.
In either case, doing
either of these integral
with Riemann sums would
be really atrocious.
So, in both cases, what
we're really happy about
is that we have these
other tools that
allow us to evaluate definite
integrals without going back
to the Riemann definition
of the integral.
So, I'm going to stop there.